in this video we will talk about the
leash nihan syndrome this video is a
high Hilt series video for USMLE step 1.
so in lishnihan syndrome is a rare
excellent disorder which is due to the
mutation of AGP rt1 gene on X chromosome
so AGP rt1 Gene is responsible for
expressing a very important protein
which is a 8gprt enzyme
it is hypoxanthine guanine
phosphoripozyl transferase this enzyme
is important for making purines which
are the building blocks for nucleic
acids like DNA and RNA
now this disorder is a x-linked
recessive disorder right
so males are more susceptible of
Contracting this disease females are
mostly carriers in very rare situations
female get also affected
now let's understand the biology behind
the lishnihan syndrome
now when DNA or RNA are degraded they
form pyrimidines and purines
now this today's discussion will be
about purines now this purines that is
adenine and guanine get broken down by a
multi-step pathway into hypoxanthine and
guanine
now this hypoxanthin and guanine is you
again utilized or rather recycled by one
enzyme known as agprt and this pathway
of recycling hypoxanthin and guanine to
form purines again is known as the
purine Salvage pathway
right
now if there isn't some error with the
AGP RT Gene then what's gonna happen
that this purine Salvage pathway will
not work in that situation this
hypoxanthin and guanine will be
repurposed to form uric acid and there
will be increase in the amount of uric
acid in the body tissues
now let's understand the pathology of
lishnihan syndrome now this increased
amount of uric acid formed in the
tissues due to faulty purine Salvage
pathway will come into blood and will
cause
hyperuricemia that is increased uric
acid in the blood now this increased
amount of circulating uric acid will get
deposited in the joints as uric acid
crystals and will form gout
now this uric acid can go to brain
can deposit as crystals and cause uric
acid toxicity leading to psychiatric
manifestations like aggression
self-mutilation
now this uric acid can get excreted by
kidney as urate crystals and can we can
get to see red orange crystals with
coming out with urine most commonly a
mother of the child will complain to you
that I can see a red orange sand in the
diaper of my baby
and finally by some unknown mechanism
the uric acid also causes muscle
dystonia or tense muscles
the hyperuricemia also causes faulty
vitamin B12 utilization leading to
megaloblastic anemia
now let's come to the clinical
presentations of lishnihan syndrome so
the main or diagnostic clinical feature
is your nail biting head banging and
self mutilating conditions they also
bite their own lips now all the apart
from all these conditions there will be
joint pins due to gout there will be
reddish discoloration of urine there
will be tense muscles and also these
wounds that they cause by
self-mutilation can get infected and can
cause superficial skin infections
now let's come to the treatment of
lishnihan syndrome
it's obvious that you cannot correct
without underlying genetic abnormality
but how we can treat the condition see
the main problem is that due to faulty
working of the AG PRT hyposanthe and
guanine is not getting converted into
purine rather they are getting converted
into uric acid now purine also gets
formed from something known as de
novosynthesis so even after the
malfunctioning of hgprt there is no such
deficiency of purine so we don't have to
address that we have to address this
increasing uric acid in the blood
is converted into uric acid by one
enzyme known as xanthine oxidase we can
block this xanthine oxidase enzyme to
reduce the amount of uric acid
production
and drugs such as alopurinol and
faboxostat exactly does the same these
are the drugs we use in treating gout
that is hyperuricemiconditions so
similarly in listening hand syndrome we
can also use these drugs to decrease the
uric acid production and by doing so we
can control all the manifestations
starting from gout
psychiatric manifestations reddish
discoloration of urine tense muscles and
so on
I hope you have understood the concept
of lishnihan syndrome in this video to
get notes on high quality flashcards you
can follow us on our Facebook page and
our Instagram at animated biology with
arpan the link will be in the
description box below
we need your support to continue to make
high quality educational content for
free you can do that by using the super
thanks icon which is present on the
bottom right corner of this video and
you can pay using paytm PayPal or UPI
you can also scan the QR code on the
screen or can support us on our patreon
page
if you wish to connect use the following
links given in the description box and
for medicine related content follow nerd
medic on YouTube the link will be in the
description box below until then bye bye
see you in the next one